[Music]
oh sorry by the way i just had to
comment what a beautiful place west
hollywood is when someone
rolls out in an unprotected left and
almost kills you and just carries on
about their day wonderful this guy
literally almost [ __ ]
t-boned the [ __ ] out of me this weekend
and i you know i just like i was
thankful like this is no [ __ ] i was
thankful for all the hours i spent in a
stupid go-kart because i genuinely feel
like that saved me for something really
bad i was like laying on the horn as i'm
like he basically just pops out he's not
looking i get on the horn he's still not
looking i'm like at an angle so i'm i'm
definitely getting clear and then he
finally like comes too he's like on his
[ __ ] phone ugh he's like oh and then
pulls his car left and i get around him
because he like kind of let off the gas
and then as i'm getting in front of him
to like
basically get back in my lane he's like
trying to cut through me and against
another car
he like immediately gets on the power
and i [ __ ] i like roll down my window
and i throw my hand out it's the most
dead [ __ ] i've ever done and i screamed
slow down
yes
and then the dudes drive like your kids
live here the dude's like oh
and then
goes the other way and just like you
know not a care in the world so it's
just really nice how la
kind of you know yeah promotes that
carefree lifestyle yeah
oops did you see that's casey neistat
seth rogen oh that whole exchange is
hilarious i thought that was pretty
funny third world [ __ ] i know i was
like that's intense casey man we might
have exposed power lines and
you know
plenty of taco carts but let's calm down
yeah i mean that yeah that was an
intense comparison to make especially
when you're casey
yeah
i don't i just feel like publicly he's
like
he's a nice guy he's nice i mean
privately he's a nice guy too but i'm
just saying like his
his purse his online persona i guess has
always been very agreeable yeah and so
to just like go on twitter like that a
public forum be like la's a third world
[ __ ] it's like damn
jesus christ bold words my brother yeah
pretty intense i can call it that
because i've been to third world
countries dude
[Applause]
[Music]
i've traveled to many a third world
countries yeah let me tell you la is
just like one yeah
[Laughter]
i've never met him so yeah i mean
i guess i just don't think he likes l.a
so our cars got this is the tweet so our
cars got robbed this morning because los
angeles is a crime riddled third world
[ __ ] of a city
okay but tremendous appreciation and
gratitude to the hard-working officers
at lapd west la who not only arrested
the [ __ ] but got all of our
stolen goods back
and then seth rogen replied and was like
dude i've been living here for so long
20 years i've lived here for over 20
years you're nuts haha it's lovely here
don't leave anything
valuable in it
uh it's called living in a big city i
agree with that though i mean i do too
but it's also like shouldn't be like a
prerequisite
that your car is gonna get broken into
if you leave [ __ ] in it in a big city
right like doesn't have to be a thing in
a big city does it not
not necessarily and it's also but like
yeah that's what i mean it's also like
casey's from new york it's like
the same shit's gonna happen there yeah
i mean the the the part to me where i'm
like bro just admit you left your [ __ ]
in your car and that was a bozo move
yeah it is a bozo move i don't i don't
give a [ __ ]
where you are where you're from leaving
nice [ __ ] in your car is just a stupid
idea yeah cause that if that assumes
that everyone in the world is not at any
point in time someone is down bad you
know what i'm saying like yeah but
you're defending robbery now
i'm not saying robbery's a good thing
i'm or like
i'm not defending it i'm saying like
it happens
you should know what happens
yeah i agree like you can't you can't
just
well i'm in a nice city so like dude i
have friends live in [ __ ]
manhattan and hermosa and
every day on their ring cameras some
[ __ ] like young kid will just be in
their neighborhood on a bicycle checking
doors i know yeah okay so yeah i agree
it's yes you should know it definitely
happens i've never left [ __ ] in my i
mean like i probably have but like yeah
not not and i i wouldn't be surprised if
i did the next day it was it was gone
right but like
also there's like all these smash and
grabs happening in california now you've
seen that [ __ ] mm-hmm like it's
obviously
increasing right yeah
so maybe that's what this is about it's
like crime is obviously getting worse in
california yeah
and maybe it's not as much in other
places i don't know i just think maybe
like i'm not saying it's right but i
think when you're in a big city
big cities just attract like all kinds
of [ __ ] you don't even know if those
people are from the town yeah yeah it's
true you know what i mean like
uh this is a weird-ass comparison to
make but when i worked at best buy we
had theft all the time but the people
who stull [ __ ] they weren't from the
area my store was located in yeah like
if they ever got caught it was like you
looked at their license and they're from
like six hours away or some crazy [ __ ]
so
i think it's just more that when you
live in a big ass city
it's not like living in a suburb or
a smaller town where the behavior is a
little bit more predictable yeah i think
it's just that it's like a big city has
unpredictability and i think the only
constants you can assume are within your
own locked doors and that's about it
yeah that's fair i also think i don't
know like with the laws in san francisco
right with like everything under a
certain amount being a misdemeanor and
all that stuff and now cars get broken
into all the time there and it's just
like something that they deal with even
if you don't leave valuables in there i
don't know i guess i'm just i follow
gary tan on twitter who's like this
investor and he's like super vocal about
how much crime is happening in san
francisco so i think i'm in an echo
chamber but yeah i mean
definitely it's not that like crime is
right but
it's just like there's seven billion
[ __ ] people on this [ __ ] planet
dude like
we
the system clearly is not figured out so
that everyone is having a good time so i
think as long as that's going on you
probably shouldn't leave cameras in your
car go back i want to read the rest of
the thread third world [ __ ]
it's definitely not a third world
country though yeah
like
yeah
i wouldn't say all that man it attracted
a lot of [ __ ] you know a lot of hot
takes seth try to make like a really
kind of dumbass joke where he's like
dude left a cool knife in my car
sometimes you get a little treat
that it was clearly sarcasm and a bunch
of like humorless political people came
up and they were like oh so seth rogen
thinks it's a treat if someone leaves
something in your car all right dude
okay
you can be mad what is it is it this one
you can be mad i guess not but i don't
personally view my car as an extension
of myself and i've never really felt
violated
any of the 15 or so times my car was
broken into once a guy accidentally left
a cool knife in my car so if it keeps
happening you might get a little trick
but it's so obviously sarcastic yeah
it's a joke then they were bringing up
all these obscure examples just being
like seth rogen thinks
they're just like jumping to the like
highest degree of like oh so if someone
gets killed in your car their brains on
the seat is a little gift you're like
[Laughter]
whatever man you win like okay
like that whole like you know i don't
view my car as an extension of myself
like that's you man you can't put that
on other people like
you can give a [ __ ] about your car yeah
but
yeah yeah i mean you know like it is
upsetting when your [ __ ] gets broken
into that is without reason or like
that's undeniable but yeah i mean i
guess yeah big city vibes bro big city
vibes but a lot of people were like yeah
i mean like this classic rich guy and
under not understanding
that things happen in a city it's like
yeah but yeah exactly he's like i think
his tweet when he's like can i not be
mad about this but comparing it to a
third world country is not the good not
the best
verbiage you could have used that's
where that's where i think you're out of
touch yeah
you can get [ __ ] jacked anywhere yeah
thanking lapd but i but yeah because
it's kind of like it's also like
contradictory to what you're saying in
the tweet to begin with like la is a
crime-riddled city
but also thanks to lapd they're not
[ __ ] batman dude yeah
but it's like then who is the tweet
aimed at like who bro
casey you're just
you left [ __ ] in your car
and it's just a bozo move bro just
it's okay to it it's okay to be they're
not mutually exclusive you can be upset
that someone broke into your [ __ ]
you can also admit that it was a bozo
move and just that's the end yeah
to me this is like i'm casey neistat i
made a mistake but
[ __ ] all if i let anyone think i i
slipped yeah let me just go ahead and
blame the whole city but he didn't have
to tweet anything at all that's what i'm
saying that's what i'm saying man
i don't know i don't know casey so he
just doesn't like la i think
yeah which is weird cause it's sick yeah
well you're from new york i mean yeah
you've [ __ ] been there yeah
you